des chefs d'État et de gouvernement du
monde entier vont faire le déplacement
pour assister aux obsèques d'Elisabeth
II qui a régné 70 ans sur le Royaume-Uni
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé en fin
d'après-midi il s'est rendu à
Westminster Hall en compagnie de son
épouse afin de saluer la dépouille de la
reine le président américain Joe Biden
c'est recueilli dans l'après-midi vous
le voyez 8 km de queue qui serpente
parfois devant des habitations aux
premières loges c'est londoniennes
assistent à ce défiler incessant on
regarde tous ces gens passés on se dit
qu'ils sont vraiment courageux après
d'interminables heures d'attente enfin
le recueillement la possibilité de
rendre hommage à Elizabeth II
[Musique]
c'est un phare qui vient de s'éteindre
une balise un repère
[Musique]
alors a été extraordinaire jusqu'au bout
puisque elle elle a disparu en quelques
heures sans embêter personne sans avoir
une agonie qui dure des heures des jours
simplement gentiment elle est morte puis
pouf demande dans l'abbaye de
Westminster et bien les places sont
extrêmement limitées un peu plus de 2000
invités seulement dont 200 anonymes
décorés en raison de leur engagement
associatif il y aura aussi des femmes de
chambre de la reine des fins l'idée pour
les autorités britanniques et bien c'est
que ces funérailles nationales ne
ressemblent pas à un sommet
international mais bel et bien à une
journée historique parmi les très
nombreux anonymes l'un des sujets de Sa
Majesté n'est pas passé inaperçue l'ex
footballeur David Beckham tenait lui
aussi à vivre ce moment historique
il a attendu 12 heures comme tout le
monde mais lui avais-tu le privilège de
rencontrer la reine
j'ai eu tellement de chances de pouvoir
vivre de tel moment dans ma vie de
pouvoir approcher sa Majesté
[Applaudissements]
les Bachus cada alors
le frère de Paul Mathias Pogba et 4
autres hommes ont été déférés devant le
juge envie de leur mise en examen ils
sont soupçonnés d'extorsion de fonds à
l'encontre du joueur de l'équipe de
France qui avait déposé plainte au mois
de juillet il avait affirmé avoir été
piégé par des hommes cagoulés et armés
qui lui avaient réclamé 13 millions
d'euros Paul Pogba dit avoir versé
100000 euros et il aurait reconnu son
frère de la lumière des terrains de
football à l'ombre d'une cellule Aminata
Diallo a passé sa première nuit en
détention mise en examen pour violence
aggraver contre son ancienne coéquipière
du PSG qui rame Rabhi là encore
délinquance et football se retrouve
mêlée la joueuse avait été violemment
frappée à la main et aux jambes à coups
de barres de fer elle a elle-même publié
les photos de ses blessures
c'est tout simple
[Rires]
pulmonaire
[Applaudissements]
elle a la morgue au nez
oui la mort au sens d'une attitude
hautaine vous êtes Chantal lades
parce que parfois elle ne sait pas qui
est à côté Christophe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gens savent pas ce qu'ils perdent
qu'est-ce que vous êtes confortable en
plus
non mais ça je trouve ça bien vous êtes
capable
de gonfler votre ventre comme une femme
enceinte et vous faites ça dans un but
bien particulier Amélie oh mais si on
peut le dire ça veut dire que vous
l'avez fait c'est dans votre vie et
pourquoi vous l'avez fait
passer plus rapidement à la caisse et
m'asseoir dans le bus mais ça c'est
arrivé une fois
[Musique]
[Rires]
Chantal concentre-toi
ça y est les 200.000 euros sont franchis
regardez la cagnotte
[Applaudissements]
Enzo à 19 ans il est le plus grand
champion de tous les quiz de France
Télévisions